hi Ali I see how are you buddy hi man
dad's coming in do you watch any of
these courtroom TV shows my loved
courtroom TV show he likes judge Marilyn
Milian from the People's Court I watched
them all yeah she's okay right you know
she's all right right you like Joe Brown
you said I do yeah I'm not a huge famine
if I had to pick one I'd pick him you
don't have to pick one there's no reason
to pick one for me I don't really watch
for the judges I love the I'm calling
them contestants I love the contestants
they really are yeah that kind of cast
but it's it's they're funny they're
amazing and they don't know they're
funny that's why they're funny right but
don't you get your fear if you lose you
get it paid for don't they pay for it so
you really not losing anything by going
on television I think they do pay for it
yeah why would you lose dignity yeah why
did a lot of dignity yeah these
arguments do not hold up in humanity and
now it's just you know this is my
ex-wife you know and she took my
lawnmower okay and she said she was
gonna give me $40 and I have a note here
if you'd like
can I see the note can I see can I see
the note well it's not the the actual
note it's a copy the notes that I made
my favorite is like they go like well I
borrowed his car and then I got a
speeding ticket so he's asking me to pay
the speeding ticket yeah just because
it's my car and like they go back and
forth minutes out of it it's nice Hetty
people are yeah look very very petty
and this is what keeps us from murdering
each other the fact that we can go to
court and work it out it's not about $40
but that's not a horror show that's TV
right it's TV if you have a major
problem and you really believe this is a
problem you can't solve it on TV no and
but that's all of TV like when you're
watching The Bachelorette right you know
I love how earnest people are when they
go I just want to make sure you're here
for the right reasons I watch it too
yeah
but I think every time they say that you
know I I don't think he's here for the
right reason right I am here for true
love to get to like episode 7 and it
starts a question wait a minute is he
here just for the cameras or is he her
for me he didn't even know you before I
got even worked out have any of them
actually worked out where they'd evolved
into a real relationship and stay
together past the next season when
they're not are you talking about
episode 7 everybody gets out of that car
and goes I think we should spend the
rest of it's right I don't know but it's
like a romantic thing you do here older
couples that have these weird stories
that I met him in a cafe you just
weren't real nice I do I said if you
walk me home I'll marry you and then
they'll a sudden Americans later when
you are 80 when you are 70 you think
tomorrow if you think you're gonna die
tomorrow if you are young and you feel
like the whole world is ahead don't beg
for a for a [ __ ] road right how did
you meet you marry 38 years which is how
did you meet your wife reality TV show I
it said you know I don't remember okay
we were in the same area we were just an
I knew her before I married her well you
can't marry Rangers but I well you can
yeah but I I knew her I knew her and I
my friends dated her and I met her from
my friend dating and then I met and then
and then she dated another friend and
then I tried and then then she just said
no to me and then she didn't know she
was with everyone why not it was your
turn it was my turn right you know so
they ruin your friendship with my
friends or her your friend did you ruin
your friendship when you dated his ex um
yes they did right yes
it did but I'm still with her and I'm
not with him did I never get back that
friendship or no no I don't care you
know that really care about old friends
if you came in and you were like yeah I
mean I've been with my wife for 38 years
but I really miss my friend Joseph like
what choice did you make their moments
ruin a good friendship sometimes that
stuff is irreparable and sometimes I
have five years later you look people
say you've been married for 38 years to
the same woman can I be honest with you
like when I married her she was like 23
and wild and crazy and fun and I'll be
honest this is not the same woman the
same name how many years into the change
what how many years into the change
oh right after I do I do
right don't say change the word that
they leave off of the vowel I do change
change change yeah it's very different
when you I know I'm happily married I'm
thrilled to be married she gets well
you're probably not the same guy or are
you no I'm not I'm not
she's mad at me now for do you guys go
to the bathroom in the shower piss yes
[ __ ] a shower oh wow yeah it's not
like I don't spend a half hour trying to
push everything right well you're a good
husband right the time right the problem
is it's under the fingernails
pushing it down you know you're right
yeah that's the issue she doesn't like
that she doesn't know how long to be
married did you start to get like
worried about germs it was that late
from the beginning or did you get late
that's why she was the cleanest girl in
the city so that's why I went out with
her I have always been a germaphobe I've
always been a germaphobe she knew that
from the beginning
she knew that from the beginning she had
to walk on towels and I had to hose her
off and it was just it's been a
nightmare
did you [ __ ] her off before every date
before every encounter I see Wow like
[ __ ] Harvey Keitel in Pulp Fiction
there's a chemical shower right above
your doorway right you just pulled this
actually been a saint and deserves a
medal for being a part of whatever my
whirlwind of existence is how is it by
is it better for you now or is it the
same it's actually better because I'm
like this at this particular moment as
you asked my medication is really
working but there are herbs and flows
through medication so right now I am so
medicated that I have no yes I'm good
what is it what is the medication do for
you does it make it
we just don't obsess as much or what is
what is the medication how does it help
you well just I've lost all sense of
fear I have no fear probably not the
best very good thing right now it's like
a good thing but I have none I can't get
my adrenaline to flow I have no fear you
could drop me off the top of a [ __ ]
building it feels like I am sitting
talking to you does it miss you mom
bully scared they want to put me on
stuff for a different reason I'm always
scared it's gonna mess up my timing or
the ability to think fast on my feet but
obviously you sound normal to me you
don't sound any different doesn't [ __ ]
up your thinking okay you guys are
really funny too I should mention that
also this Saturday Evan there's an
Instagram do you ever watch animals
doing things I've seen animals do stuff
yes no not in Saturday Howie Mandel's
animals doing things Oh a new show home
based on the app based on the the
Instagram page oh and you just get to
announce like hey tiger
doing something that's exactly what I do
it's so stupid that they would do that
but they did and it's just the animals
are doing things Howie Mandel is doing
nothing just announcing what the animals
are doing thank you okay now here's a
raccoon it just does things and you
could watch that for yourself I have
nothing to do with it right I have the
easiest jobs in the world I'm not the
judge on AGT it's not really a judge I'm
doing what people are doing at home
alone in their underpants on the couch
they gave me pants and a check and I go
and do fun gig isn't it we just kind of
talk about people who are performing
that's a fun game how do you guys
probably have to there's a preparation
some preparation that goes into this
level of preparation sherry is a little
I love it you know what I'm noticing so
we're here at a serious radio and you
there is probably I don't know how many
shows at once going like there's
probably 20 30 different shows in
different booths
these are your in little glass aquariums
Radio aquariums and you could walk down
the hall and you go there's that show
and there's that show and you could wave
at them but you are enclosed in drapery
yeah why it's right why is it there's
nudity on the on the screen we can't
have the curtains open because it's like
a human resources issues game likes to
look up photos of analingus yeah every
show yeah I don't want people forming it
yeah we like to have nudity on the
screen because which we're fine for it
cuz we got the curtain if you'd like to
see anything we'll show you yeah and and
just show me stuff but I won't we won't
we don't have to talk about see the
inside Quincy episode yeah oh my god I
didn't mean to embarrass you now it's
hard to concentrate but there's a big
there's a like a yeah more curtains
right yeah that's that's when you know
that's when you know there's good stuff
really let's go back to let's go back to
Howie wait how he's enjoying that [ __ ]
man he was happy just sit quiet and
watch me in photos I heard you and Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts this morning you
guys weren't talking you're just looking
at this nothing I love that that's right
I can't they just enjoy you know they
say silence is golden I think there's
got to be more silence on radio there
really has to be people who are driving
right now and people who are listening
to the show maybe they just want us to
shut the [ __ ] up and give you a moment
wherever you are let's give you a moment
to Center yourself now that's it
that's it I was a show this morning with
Howie well I had some time to myself
relaxing it is relaxing it's never quiet
this is yap yap yap yap yap how does a
Howard compare to or I guess now Simon
compared to doing the show with Howard
very different yeah I'll tell you the
biggest I'll tell you the biggest
difference and I love Howard and I'm a
huge fan of Howard and I'm a friend of
Howard but all time you know that
because like you you know it's a Howard
has to get up early I don't know if you
guys get up earlier if you get up early
not necessarily as he does but we get up
yeah we have to be on we started eight
so yeah those who you started eight so
but he's up at like 4:00 in the morning
right so when he was part of America's
Got Talent
not only did they move the
to New York but they you know we started
promptly maybe at 10:00 or maybe at
11:00 you know when he finished if it
was a radio day then he had to go do the
ready and then we would work till maybe
6:00 or 7:00 at night and then be gone
Simon on the other hand I don't think he
has seen noon I don't think he's ever
seen one I don't think he's up at about
2:00 or 3:00 in the afternoon Wow so we
don't start shooting till 4:00 or 5:00
and we go till 1:00 in the morning what
is it about that chair that they just
let that person Alice's chair that's the
Alpha chair like you shouldn't he
switched chairs from Howard you know
that was my chair but but well first of
all it's about those guys shouldn't it
just be like the show starts at this
time like this is so be there at this
you want to get somebody to be on the
show if they wanted however if they want
a Simon Cowell to certain of probably
concessions they had to make and that
was one of them yeah and that's who
these people you know the the thing I
remember most about Howard is so they
moved the whole show here in New York
and Heidi Mel B and at that time the
cannon lived in California so the three
of us lived in California so we on you
know in August it goes live we had to
get on Tuesdays we got on a plane in Los
Angeles all three of us were on the same
plane we flew for six hours
we've land here they drive us into the
city we have to go to the hotel change
put our clothes take a quick shower get
all go down to Radio City Music Hall
after seven hours and then we're gonna
go live and we'd be walking down the
hall and Howard would be walking the
other way and Howard would go oh [ __ ]
traffic how does that not start fights
eventually like how did how do you guys
not start resenting the fact that we're
all uprooting ourselves you know what I
don't think either any Mel Heidi
myself or Nick have that gene of
resentment I think we were thrilled to
be working with Howard it was fun being
here in New York it was fun being at
Radio City Music Hall it's fun working
with Simon - Simon is the you know gives
the show a gravitas he's got
billboard right now maybe four or five
spots with all his talent so when he you
know and I just I don't know if you
watched last week or have you seen it on
YouTube but my golden buzzer
is gonna be the new biggest star this is
thirteen year old little awkward girl
that becomes Janis Joplin and just has
exploded and had over a hundred million
hits incredible on digital since Tuesday
which by which scheduled do you prefer
the Howard schedule you're done by 6:00
p.m. or this one where you go to 1:00
a.m.
it depends what time of day you ask me
and ask me now in the morning I was
never happy to get up early in the
morning I'm not really a morning person
but I want to go home at night so if you
ask me at 11:00 or 12:00 at night
if you're happy still being here I'd
like to be home sure or someplace but I
love you know sitting there if I'm gonna
be up late I might as well watch these
amazing and sometimes ridiculous you
know acts well the show business it
feels like things should be done at
night watch somebody performing at 8:00
p.m. or 9 p.m. than it is at 3:00 in the
afternoon well have you ever had to do
comedy have you ever done comedy in the
morning like I'll get hired from new
owners in a terrible a corporate
corporate thing where it's brunch when
they smile or laugh you shouldn't see
eggs in somebody I don't want to see egg
you know I don't like I don't do
particularly well at those gigs but the
afternoon gigs are never good they never
find everything it's not meant you're
not meant to be to doing stand-up at
[ __ ] 3 o'clock in the afternoon no
you're not it's not not in daylight not
in any daylight we'll say are you doing
early show Saturday 6 p.m. show in a
club and they have like curtains oh it's
black top but you can see a little bit
of daylight coming through the side of
the car you know this just feels people
aren't as look for some is loose it just
feels wrong to be brightness with
daylight and speaking of things
happening in our natural times did you
wake up to watch your girl in the Royal
Wedding no because I resent her because
for not inviting me so that resentment
gene did pop in it did remember yes that
I was just talking about that yeah I
guess there's one well I'm invited
because the whole cast of suits was
there but she was also on Deal or No
Deal or No Deal and there's only you all
you're the host here the show and that
was a big break for her huge I don't
know that she would have gotten suits if
it wasn't for me I don't think so can I
be honest with you and I don't remember
her at all
nothing I was told that she was in right
all right I was showing the pictures I
was there she was there I don't remember
her right but you have the photos with
the princess girl but you don't know I
have no idea right I don't know anything
about you maybe you didn't talk to her
maybe she's hiding in the hallway and
you were distracted and you blew her off
and then she's now the princess she's
like I'm not inviting him he wasn't nice
to me when I worked with him so even the
name
they said Megan Merkel you're like I've
never heard of the person before man I
didn't know that name right did not know
that name I don't know I don't I still
it's and I'm trying to like have a
moment in your memory right yeah where I
go people are talking about her and I'd
like to like pop one one thing what's
your fondest memory with her yeah your
fondest your best megan merkel memory
from Deal or No Deal Marco Marco Marco
Merkel Marco do you know her name Ali oh
there was one time I said I'll never
forget this I said to her
Megan hmm open the case
and she did she did she just that thing
this just cracked open and the amount of
money but I remember that the way she
opened it was God show is coming back
now I've arises CNBC and and you know
what the the beauty of it is and and for
no other reason but to create another
Duchess yet important how great would it
be if you guys could get her to do it we
didn't even ask we're gonna ask you
should know she was on would she do one
episode without it being announced not
being talked about no one mentions that
she just does the show and that's the
end of it what night are you gonna be on
CNBC I don't know okay because I watch
CNBC at night what you do because I got
a couple shows that I like on there
right and I get mad when other shows
replace those shows would you get mad if
my show replays no because I do like
Deal or No Deal
okay I could see myself watching we're
gonna throw another show out I did I
know because they sit there and they'll
do like Shark Tank from 7:00 p.m. to
2:00 a.m. yeah I love those nights yes
and so when they put on like a different
show I won't mention because now you're
in the CNBC family I don't want to throw
that on though those throw it under the
bus but I different show that they're
not shark tank I'll be like we're shark
tank but Deal or No Deal brand new
episodes and the allure No Deal that is
a great home for it it's it's there make
sense it does make sense it makes sense
its money its money its negotiating
right it's greed it's the royal family
potentially yeah it's actually
potentially not necessarily but
potentially do you promote it you say
and we have a very very special what do
they call the people have turned the
briefcase ladies okay we have a very
special briefcase lady and then just
bring coming back and everyone think
it's her right tune in but just want the
other ones just some others are a very
special one very special right like a
special needs one yeah
very special yeah very special just like
just get people to watch it so you never
you didn't even watch it on tape the
Royal Wedding
you think you cuz you didn't care no I
did see I so when you start has ace did
you go like oh she's pretty
wait that's all ya know did you watch
the original Deal or No Deal
yeah sure do you remember her I know no
no reco
never any of the women no no I remember
you I remembered maybe that favorites
though did they they did how many were
there
26 okay you know who else was a Deal or
No Deal model who Chrissy Teigen
really yeah do you remember her being a
dealer No Deal model no memory no she
let you know she let me know and it was
it was new information for you when I
did the what's it called Sports
Illustrated swimsuit edition special no
I did a piece on that and she was there
cuz she was the cover girl at the time
and she goes you don't remember me
number whatever number she was it's so
funny like it's because JLo was
originally on in living color as a
dancer yeah like you got to be nice to
everybody because you never know who's
that background person or whatever who's
gonna [ __ ] you know be the biggest
person in Hollywood yeah if you don't
realize you need to be nice to every
gorgeous dancer and model yeah that's
right cause you don't know what they're
gonna write by the way how he has dates
on sale to just go to Howie Mandel calm
I don't know but yeah it's a great gig I
the Bergen Performing Arts Center in
Englewood tomorrow is NYC D Theater it's
in Westbury and then you can go to
Oklahoma or Atlantic City or Key West
coming up through the end of July at my
own club and Atlantic City the Taj Mahal
was just bought by the Hard Rock Casino
okay in Atlantic City and they're
opening up the Howie Mandel comedy club
oh yeah so you're doing that I'm gonna
I'm gonna appear there cuz it's my club
sure and I'm gonna shoot a special there
on July 3rd and 4th that's great that's
amazing yeah did you ever stop doing
dates or you kept you know I still do
almost 200 a year oh you are yeah that's
my favorite that's that's what I do
regardless of anything else and it kind
of keeps me and you do it too it keeps
you in touch with people yeah and it
also reminds me that I'm never doing as
good as I think what I'm still sweating
ticket sales now man that was great I
shot a special I'm like [ __ ] I got to do
extra presses have sold yeah that's one
thing I'll never be happy with is
worrying about ticket sale you just you
never ever get over worrying about
ticket sales I do because really I just
enjoy myself I don't care you don't care
if anybody shows up in fact when I'm
alone it's just
more freeing which goes for what our new
plan for the radio show is just let
people be alone in their cars without us
with no noise no no no audience night
certainly no laughing and you could sit
and just look at your Instagram thing
look at animals doing things right and
then watch it on Nat Geo you have a
ritual before you go on or do you show
up and go on show up and go on yeah
nothing there's no people always say you
know if they're if they're there before
the show I'll give you a minute to go
prep and I go okay but I don't know what
to do you have a ritual it's gotta pay
before I I need if it's just if it's a
two-person show I gotta know what your
last bit is so I can piss and if the if
it's a three-person show I tell hostess
got to do two in between
I just gotta pee that's it yeah well no
matter what how do you time you're like
what if you don't have to pee he pisses
every time and literally okay I'll stand
over the toilet and just lightly brush
my nipple cause it relaxes me and makes
me go to the bathroom a hundred I wish I
wasn't yeah a hundred percent serious
because there's something about that
it's some type of a [ __ ] female
estrogen thing I'm sure it helps you go
to the bathroom no not another one your
nipple to pee the fact that why do you
need to pee like you don't if you don't
have the urge why are you going B it's
the same reason that the fly in the
aisle in case I have to write I don't
want to be uncomfortable on stage the
idea being a minute in our set and
having to pay as I can exhale it becomes
all it's all you can think